Aaron was in full compliance with
California law but the federal
government says the California law is
irrelevant
Aaron Sandusky has been sentenced to ten
years in federal prison for his role in
operating the medical marijuana
dispensaries known as g3 holistic in
California's Inland Empire reason TV has
documented Sandusky's continued legal
battle since November 2011 it's a fight
that he's always said he's been willing
to take to the finish I'm gonna defend
what I believe is right and if I have to
go to jail for 20 years defending a then
so be it
after the sentencing Sandusky's lawyer
and supporters gathered in front of the
courthouse to sound off about what they
see as a miscarriage of justice he had a
trial where there was no defense because
he admitted that he cultivated and
distributed marijuana and so today was a
sentencing day and under federal law he
had to receive a minimum of a 10-year
sentence the medical marijuana movement
is strong and it's growing in popularity
this judge needs to catch up with the
times but what happened today was just
the height of injustice during the
sentencing judge Percy Anderson said I'm
going to take a stand for the rule of
law is what I'm going to do in this case
and that Sandusky had lost his way about
what's right and wrong
his moral compass the smugness of the
the judges and the officials in the room
they they had an appearance of looking
upon us with pity like like we were so
misguided and in fact the judge said
that in his sentencing of mr. Sandusky
that we are lost and I think that to say
that 40 or 50 percent of the United
States populace is lost is reflecting
that they're completely out of touch we
disagree as to what the rule of law is
we say that under the Commerce Clause
the federal Congress does not have the
authority to pass laws regulating
marijuana distribution no totally within
one state such as California so we're
also upholding them trying to uphold the
rule of law just at our notion of what
the law is in
the Constitution not just statutes
passed by Congress and duskie made a
statement to the court and did not
express remorse for selling medical
marijuana but instead said I want to
apologize to the people indicted with me
they were victimized by the federal
government he wasn't sure whether he was
going to speak because what they want
you to do the government's you to do
when you're in the sentencing they want
you to have remorse and they want you to
you know apologize and to feel like I'm
sorry I I committed a crime I'm like I
do this well he doesn't feel that he
still feels really strongly about his
decisions about what he was doing he
feels that what he was doing was right
he's very passionate and very caring and
generous and everybody here that is is
here to support him or have been witness
to that the next step here is to file
the notice of appeal and take this case
to the US Court of Appeals for the Ninth
Circuit hopefully we'll get a better
reception but it does require a little
judicial creativity and following the
Constitution as opposed to statutes do
you feel like this has all been worth it
you know I have mixed feelings be
obviously for four reasons
I don't want him to be in prison he
doesn't belong there he doesn't deserve
to be there and it's not worth it
because the outcome is not the outcome
that you will ultimately want but
not over and I do stand behind him 100%
this is something that hit so strongly
about and you know unfortunately we're
in the position that we're in now but I
still stand behind it
Oh